The Steam Machine has been a runaway
success, but that's in spite of a
critical, maybe even criminal mistake
from Valve. No, I don't mean the single
channel memory or the pedestrian
performance. I'm talking, of course,
about the name Steam Machine.
WHERE IS THE GOD DANG steam valve? I
mean, the class action lawsuit for false
advertising practically writes itself.
But worry not, gay men, for we have
taken it upon ourselves to write this
terrible wrong and put the steam back in
the steam machine. Literally, this is a
working steam engine. And when we're
done, we'll be using it to put Valve's
engineering back on the rails and cool
our steam machine. Now, this might seem
like a purely silly because we can
project, and it is, but it also serves a
very real purpose. See, Valve did make
one actual error in the steam machine's
design. They neglected to allow any user
control of the fan curve, which has
resulted in thermal throttling for some
users. So, by using a 3D printed fan and
some pulleys along with some help from
Valve.
This one, not that one. We are going to
write this wrong once and for all. Or
maybe we're going to waste a bunch of
time and money and hurt ourselves in the
process. Who knows? What I do know is
how to segue to our sponsor
>> UG Green. Their Magflow Pro is a liquid
cooled G2 enabled 25 watt power bank
where you can see the liquid cooling in
action. Wa. Check it out. The links
below. This project was actually
inspired by a discussion in our weekly
writer meeting.
>> I wanted to water cool the steam
machine.
>> To which I replied, Samsons did it.
Samsons did it. And we actually have
done. You pretty much name anything and
we have water cooled it at some point. I
wanted to do something new. The first
reactions to my steam cooled steam
machine concept were not good. No, they
[laughter] were not.
But but as it so often does, AliExpress
saved the day. See, it turns out for
about $300,
you can get a few hours of wholesome fun
for the whole family and end up with
your very own fully armed and
operational steam battle engine station
at the end of it. This particular one is
a single cylinder design from Rocking
Whale that is rated for up to 015
horsepower and 600 g per cm of torque.
No idea what that equates to, but it
says it'll do something like 3,000 RPM,
which happens to be about two and a half
times faster than the stock steam
machine. So hopefully this thing will be
suitable to amp up our cooling. The
output though is just this rod right
here. No electric generation is
included, so we will need to make some
modifications in order to actually use
its power. We should also run some quick
before tests just to see if what we're
going to do, you know, even helps. If it
doesn't lower our temperatures, then
it'll be clear why Valve didn't go this
route.
>> Oh, yes.
>> That would be the reason.
>> 100%. It wasn't efficient.
>> I'm going to get those tests going.
>> All right, let's get to it.
>> I have some pics of what the idle
temperature is like, but I want to see
what it's like under load.
>> Idle ain't the issue, brother.
>> It might be an issue for our, you know,
our steam engine. Finding the right dial
to keep it at like an idle constant
going is actually really tough because
you end up using the steam
>> and your pressure reduces and you can
only build pressure at the same rate at
which you can boil water. Looking pretty
good. GPU is at 85°. Our CPU is at 83
and we're hitting 1200 RPM on the fan.
This really highlights that the Steam
Machine while compact and quiet is not
the coolest running on the market.
>> You want to try one other game or is
that Do you think that's enough?
>> I don't think it matters.
>> Sure. Because as long as it's apples to
apples.
>> Yeah.
>> Or steamed apples to regular
>> boiled apples is what I prefer.
>> No, I prefer my ham steamed.
>> Okay.
[laughter]
>> Speaking of Simpsons did it.
>> I don't I've never seen Simpsons. It
really doesn't want to go in for
surgery.
>> I don't blame it. This is going to be a
very elective surgery. [laughter]
>> You will not be better when we're done.
>> We wo wo wo. You don't know that. We're
adding like a third arm
>> faster. Yes.
>> Would you you'd be more efficient with a
third arm? If you were to have a third
arm, where would you want it to grow?
>> I mean, you know, there's the obvious.
[laughter]
>> Have you actually taken this apart yet?
>> No, I haven't. But I assume I'm going to
start with these screws.
>> Correct. You only actually need
>> precision screwdriver. ltstore.com.
>> I was going to say one bit, but there
you go.
>> I could still use the
>> Those are captive. Those two.
>> Oh, okay.
>> And then you need to undo four more. The
feet. So, get at those feet.
>> You want to show them our fan?
>> Oh, yes. This fan right here is 3D
printed on our SLS printer, which means
it's actually made of nylon, which is
some of the same material that the
screwdriver, like the OG screwdriver was
made of. And the way that we achieved,
you know, getting the exact same model
for this fan is we had TA from the labs
3D scan it and Justin cleaned it up in a
3D modeling software. 3D scanning
software has gotten good enough where
you can just like take a real world
object like this fan and create a one
for one like for like. Also, at the same
time, Noctua released the files,
>> ladies and gentlemen.
>> We got them
>> for the geometry of their fan blades.
Not quite exactly the same. Obviously,
you won't have their highquality motors
necessarily, but we were actually able
to swap out the original blade design
with a Noctua inspired one to I don't
know, maybe it'll run a little quieter.
>> Oh, I really doubt that. [laughter]
>> We'd have no way of measuring it over
the sound of that steam engine, but a
girl can dream, right? The point is this
worked out really well because while
Valve has done a pretty good job of
partnering with iFixit to provide
replacement parts, there currently is no
way for us to get our hands on another
one of these fans short of buying
another steam machine, which there is no
way for us to get our hands on. Let's uh
do not put it on that end. Thank you.
>> Oh god, there's a board there.
>> Yeah, you'll break these ends off.
>> That's crazy.
>> Yeah. What you're going to want to do is
we're going to need to remove the
antenna. These two. You need to remove
this front daughter board.
>> Sure. to get at it.
>> I'll take you apart and I'll put you
back together better than before.
>> Lionus's monster.
>> There we go. Just like that.
>> And that's that. Oh, there's our power
supply. There's our another daughter
board.
>> The main board is sandwiched in between.
>> You know, getting at the SSD, not bad.
Getting at the RAM,
>> it sucks.
>> Kind of a pain. Really impressive.
>> It even gets all like the details like
little like standoff points or whatever.
All right, let's talk about gears. To
hook our steam machine up to our
steam machine, first we boil water that
creates steam which drives this piston
right here. And then the flywheel right
here, the weight keeps the momentum
going during the peacon trough of our
piston's movement where there is no
power generation. Now, normally this
shaft here would drive something like a
boat propeller or the wheels on a train,
but instead we're going to hook up one
of these [music] gears. Then we're going
to hook them up to pulleys to turn our
fan. So, by using a combination of
different gear sizes that we can attach
either here on the steam engine or here
on the fan hub, we can actually create a
number of different gear ratios. One one
should be fine to start with, but I
suspect we're probably going to end up
with like a 3:1 because we actually need
to get up to 9,000 RPMs.
>> I'm to I'm totally kidding. It's more so
we can run our engine more economically
at a lower RPM, but then obviously still
spin the fan faster than the valve could
normally do it, [music]
>> right?
>> Yeah. Get wrecked, valve engineers.
>> I think we should stick with the middle
gear first. So, let's get this one off.
>> Okay, middle gear solid. Before I attach
it though, we actually want to put the
whole fan back on because otherwise we
won't be able to get the back plate over
whatever gear. So,
>> see, when the parents of Valve's
engineers look in the mirror and they
[music] go, "What mistakes did we make?"
A not steam powered steam machine is at
the top of that list. You got to wonder,
does Valve see stuff like this? And go,
yes, cool. Very smart. [laughter]
>> No, Gabin is relaxing on his yacht
going, "What an idiot." I actually think
that the folks at Valve would be very
into something like this.
>> Why don't you message Gabin? You should
email him.
>> I have. I did. I tried to get him on to
build a PC and I did not get a reply
which um means no. The back of the
machine is more colored than it used to
be.
>> Won't include that.
>> You know you love it.
>> We are going to release steam. That is
>> Oh no.
>> Where did this come from? I have one
extra screw.
>> Uh oh, there he goes. Yeah,
we're more efficient than the valve
engineers. That's all that means.
>> Why do they need so many?
>> I also am realizing a problem now. The
screws that we would normally screw on
the back plate are captive. It can just
sit there.
>> You can get a captive screw out.
>> No, no, I don't want to like ruin it
that hard.
>> No, no, it's fine. I forget what they're
called, but it has a little um thingamab
booer on it. And now it's almost off.
>> No, stop.
>> Yeah, there. See, I have it. I didn't
even lose it. So, now we could put it
back on and it could be self captive
once more. No, stop taping it. That's so
janky.
>> Yeah, but I It's not janky.
>> Oh, this this is janky. Oh, editor,
insert the part where the steam machine
explodes.
>> No, look. Look. It's screwed in. It's
screwed in. It grabs.
>> Yeah, it's cuz I'm taping it.
>> No, it's not cuz you're taping it. I'll
tape you. There. Look at that. Quality
modification.
>> This is about to get so bad.
>> I have not actually seen this steam
engine fired up yet. I finished the
model and I went, "Okay, I can't wait to
try this out." Turns out you need steam
engine oil. So, I look up steam engine
oil. I go, "Okay, well, what's the
easiest, quickest replacement for steam
engine oil?" Nothing. Because steam
engine oil, aside from, you know, having
the correct weight for steam engines,
contains animal tallow. So, I had to
order this from all the way down in the
States to be used once for this project
and then never again. You cannot make
steam without heat. So, we've got to put
alcohol in this little alcohol burner
that sits under the water boiler inside
the black tank. Glug it, Elijah.
>> We made one slight modification. Not
alcohol, methyl hydrate, though. We
tried actually a couple different fluids
to see which one will burn the hottest,
and this is the hottest one we have in
the shop. So, Oh,
>> I think we're getting there.
>> Yeah, I think that's good.
>> Okay, the next thing we do, and this was
nowhere in the instructions. So, I had
to look up another hobbyist channel to
find out where to put the steam [music]
engine oil. Goes in here. How much do we
need?
>> Like, not a lot is my understanding.
>> She full.
>> I hardly know her.
>> That's what I was thinking, but I was
like, that doesn't make sense.
>> Who cares?
>> It's still funny.
>> We're steam cooling a steam machine. So,
we got to light the burner before we
slide it in the butt.
>> You need to add water as well.
>> Oh, right. Where's my water at?
>> Now, I think the capacity of this
machine is about 200 ml.
>> So,
>> so just eyeball it.
Thanks. [laughter]
>> Almost. And done.
>> Do we want to just fire it up before we
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> This is a safety release valve right
here.
>> This is effectively our throttle. This
controls how much of our steam is going
to come out of here and drive the
piston. We can't even fire this up until
we reach around I think it's like 3 to 4
kg per centime squared. Okay. You ready?
>> Hand not on the trigger.
I didn't see it on fire. I was testing.
>> Yeah, it's on fire, Elijah.
>> I don't see it.
>> It is burning.
>> Is it?
>> You can see.
>> Stop.
>> I'm like,
>> it's definitely on fire. It's on fire.
>> I don't feel it.
>> It is on fire.
>> Oh. OH,
>> she's going to burn more as it gets not
overfilled. I did overfill it a little
bit. In you go, I guess.
And now we play the waiting game. Oh
yeah, you can see that.
>> Oh yeah, it's making a little It made a
little bubble fart. I have seen a bubble
fart.
>> Oh, it's it's starting to go up pretty
decently now.
>> It's going. She's boiling now. We're
getting pressure build up. Two. So at
three, we get to turn it on.
>> Yeah. Well, it can't start on its own.
It's not that sophisticated. We actually
have to give it kind of like a H. Also,
fun fact, this little switch here lets
it go in either direction. [music]
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah, but you have to stop it in between
switching.
>> It's going.
>> Well, okay. So, we're going to go this
way. Oh, wow. Oh, look at her go. Oh,
okay.
>> It's kicking off like something.
>> Is it Does it sound like it's
>> Wow. Did that burn through your gloves?
>> Nope.
>> Okay.
>> Is that pressure valve not working
properly? We may not be able to build
pressure. That would be very trace
unfortunate. You know what? Let's do the
test fire anyway.
>> Hey. Hey. Oh. How you doing there,
buddy?
>> Holy.
>> Whoa. It's shaking.
Okay.
>> This is going to sound like a dumb
comment. It does sound like an engine. I
[laughter]
I was just kind of like I don't know
what I expected.
>> Well, she's clearly working enough to
spin a fan. Should we give it a shot? I
put in way too much steam engine oil.
>> Oh, are you
>> You can see it kind of crapping out the
exhaust pipe, but that that's fine. That
>> matching colors.
>> Yeah. I'll just take a like little piece
of shop towel here.
>> Clean up for yourself.
>> Let's give it a shot. I mean, what are
we waiting for?
>> Let's use the vice here.
>> Steam engine goes there. We got the
>> We got pulley.
>> Uh belt.
>> Can you bring it any closer?
>> Don't worry about it.
>> If you could obtain me something about
the thickness of a PC cooling fan. Let's
get them toward the front of the sea
machine. So, it's kind of hanging off of
the belt at the back.
>> Yeah, cuz that'll keep the tension on
it.
>> Here's your power. We're putting it
right under where the water's going to
drip, but that's okay.
>> Okay.
>> And what makes that okay exactly?
>> Uh cuz we'll [laughter]
Yeah,
>> that safety release valve is definitely
not supposed to be releasing right now.
I don't want to mess with it while it's
very hot.
>> Yeah,
>> we're only able to build to about 2 and
1/2. But realistically, I think we've
got plenty for what we're trying to do.
It just affects my ability to open the
throttle up more. We should start
cooling it very quickly here.
>> Oh, that's a lot of water.
>> All the paper and towels.
>> It's good. It's good. It's good. She's
good. She's good. She's good. She's
good.
[laughter]
Oh my god, it's so amazing. This is so
much better than I could have possibly
hoped for. Oh my goodness. This is the
most posty thing that we have done in
years. [laughter] We're at idle right
now and our GPU is at about 37. Our CPU
is at 52. Hold on.
Oh, the CPU went down by one degree, but
No, it's back up. Never mind. [laughter]
>> Okay. Okay. the fan.
>> It's going It's blowing air.
>> Yeah.
>> Wo.
>> Wait, that means we're going the wrong
way.
>> Okay. Switch. Yeah. Switch the
direction.
>> Okay.
>> Yes. Now it's blowing the correct way.
Okay.
>> Uh, we're at the same here. I'll give
her a little bit more beans.
>> Oh, we got the CPU under 50 for the
first time.
>> All right. Let's go, boys.
>> It's about 4950. It's bouncing back and
forth, but that was the coldest it had
been yet.
>> I'm running out of pressure here. I'm
going to idle her for a little bit.
>> Let's fire up a game
>> and see how we do at the 1:1 ratio. I
suspect it's the answer is going to be
not very good.
>> Then we throw the 3:1 on and see how we
do.
>> All right.
>> Okay.
>> She's blowing heat.
>> Oh, totally. There. There is absolutely
heat coming off that. Hold on.
>> Trying to Yeah. Yeah. It's shooting a
lot of shoo [laughter] that I'm a little
worried about.
>> Gabon will send us a new one, right?
>> No. Oh,
>> I asked them if I could even buy a
second one in the leadup to the embargo
and they go completely ghosted me.
>> I can't wait for this one to break the
uh the Steam Frame subreddit. It's like,
wow, we've got Linus steam cooling the
Steam Machine before the Steam Frame.
>> I will say this, our solution does turn
gaming into a twoman operation.
>> No, it's gaming with a friend now.
That's the only difference.
>> Uh-huh. Turn any game into friend slop.
>> Okay, I am about to go to the same area
where I was. Give me a second here.
Wait, what was our temperatures?
>> Uh, 85 on GPU and 82 83 on CPU. What?
>> We're at 70 on the GPU and 50. Oh, no.
65 on the CPU.
>> Shut up.
>> Yeah. Yeah. [laughter]
Wait, I'm going to double check the
settings. No, it's still 4K and our
texture quality is still set on medium.
It's actually cooling it [laughter]
better.
There's no way. That's crazy. We have no
idea what RPM it's spinning at.
>> We don't know where the tachometer is. I
was ask
>> I was asking a bunch of people today and
they don't know where it is.
>> All right.
>> Can you crank it if we have enough
pressure built?
>> Elijah, I can literally crank that.
>> Hit me.
>> I am your soldier boy.
>> Well, it started to heat up.
>> What?
>> I think it's just because we've been
playing a little longer now cuz I'm at
80 on the GPU and 70 on the CPU. That,
dude, that looks so cool. Now
that we're bound by the rate at which we
can boil new fluid, you can you can hear
it.
>> It's turning down a little bit. We're
getting up to like 82, 83 on the GPU.
>> We might need more speed.
>> Let's change our gear ratio. So, we're
going to put this on the output of our
steam machine and this on the fan hub of
our steam machine.
>> And that should really rip it.
>> Oh my god, I love this. like a greasy
wet steamy love.
>> Okay, thank you for that.
>> Oh, we might need more water. We're
almost out of water.
>> Are we?
>> Okay, let's shut her down.
>> Yeah, I'll turn the steam machine. Wait,
which steam machine?
>> You turn that steam machine off and I'll
turn this steam machine off. I got to
let off a little steam first.
>> It's like the evolution of technology.
Like [laughter]
>> how this became this.
>> This is just made of TPU, which is kind
of like a more rubbery material. And you
can actually just have a program that
says, "How many teeth do you want and
how much spacing?" And it will just make
the belt for you. Lionus, you need to
start that.
>> Why? What are you at?
>> We're at 74 on the GPU and 92 on the
CPU.
>> Uh,
me when I see you. Okay. [laughter]
Oh god. Ew. Oh, it's Oh my god, that's a
lot. Ouch. Hot.
Uh, no. No. Stay away. Stay away.
There's more paper towel there. No. No.
I got it. I got it.
Okay. How you doing? How you doing?
Temps. Temps.
>> Uh,
>> we got this.
>> Oh, I came down. I'm at under 70 on the
GPU and about 80 on the CPU.
>> Wa.
Oh, that is way more air.
>> She's blowing. [laughter]
>> There's There's some air coming off of
that.
>> I need so little on the top gear in
order to really spin that thing. Like
you can see it. She's a little hot and
bothered. I would be too if you're
touching it like that. Our temperatures
are the lowest they've been though.
Well, lowest for starting this time. 50
on the GPU, 65 on the CPU. I start
walking around here. We're still a bit
warm.
>> Don't worry about it.
>> But you could ramp the speed up.
>> Oh, yeah. I'm barely even going.
>> Yeah,
>> I'm not even sweating yet. I mean, I'm
like splooing all over the place, but
sweat. No.
>> What's our pressure like?
>> Our pressure is not great, honestly.
We're only around 1 kg per cm squared.
But but no, that's okay cuz we were at
like half before.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah, I can give her more. I just want
to see where we end up with like a
sustainable I could run this till I run
out of fuel
>> cuz our GPU is at 75 right now, buddy.
>> Yeah. And our CPU is at about 67 69.
Like this is lower than what we were
doing before. And
>> this is the lowest we've seen yet.
>> Can I be honest? While louder than the
stock Steam Machine, it's not as bad as
I thought it was going to be. At least
at this one,
>> it is a way cooler sound.
>> Do you want to crank her up?
>> Before we do that, I actually want to
put the front cover on because we were
kind of hacking a little bit before, but
I think we can beat Valve solution even
with the cover on.
>> It did go up a tiny bit when you put it
on. We're above 80 on the GPU now and
about 76
77 on the CPU.
>> So, it's adding a little bit, well, a
significant amount more air resistance.
We're at 84 on the GPU, 76 on the CPU.
Nothing's changed.
>> I mean, I can tell you she's blowing
heat.
>> It's It's not really changing much.
>> Give her a sec. Just wait. She's going
to go to 82.
>> Oh, 69 on the CPU.
Nice.
>> Nice. Oh, we're at 66 on the CPU. Oh,
never mind. 70. I think we put too much
water in and so it's hard to [music]
build pressure. The higher gear ratio
and the additional air restriction is
definitely making a difference.
>> Yeah,
>> like she's she's struggling to push.
Hold on. I'm going to Okay, let's just
let's just remove this again. How do we
do without the face plate?
>> Uh still about 82 on the GPU, but we're
under 70 on the CPU now. 81 on the GPU.
80 on the GPU. Oh, it touched 80 on the
GPU. Ah, 70 on the CPU. So, it's within
like a degree or two right now. Slightly
better performance. Way more work than
it's worth. Okay, I'm going to run the
bare minimum so that we can hopefully
build some pressure again.
>> I'm kind of impressed with how low of an
RPM you can go on this thing.
>> Well, that's the purpose of the
flywheel, right? Yeah.
>> Is it keeps it going until the next
power stroke. Wow, it looks so cool when
you have it running really slow. Oh
yeah, dude.
>> Now I assume we're getting a little bit
hotter.
>> Yeah, 88 on the GPU, but we're still at
about 65 on the CPU.
>> But I am building pressure again. I'm up
to about 1 and 1/2. And we will have way
more steam to do a longer run at higher
RPM cuz some of the water's gone. Oh, I
need a little longer, Captain.
>> We're at 71 on the CPU liners. I don't
know how much longer we've got.
>> I need a LITTLE LONGER, CAPTAIN.
>> 95 on the GPU. I'm almost at two. So, is
this you charging before like a CS2
game?
>> I think so.
>> And then when you're like ready to
compete,
>> I AM FULLY CHARGED.
>> OH, 96 on the GPU.
>> Okay. Okay. Let's give her
>> Here we go.
>> Okay.
Oh, it's red. The light is red on the
steam machine cuz we're overheating.
>> No. No. We got this. We got this.
Come get a closeup. Get a closeup of
this. This is crazy.
>> Oh my god. God, we're coming down so
fast. We're at 88 now on 87 on the GPU,
86 on the GPU,
61 on the CPU, 85 on the GPU, 84. Let's
go. [screaming]
It came down 10° pretty much like that.
or as I call it, an LTT win. [laughter]
Sure, it might not be as quiet. It might
not look as sleek. It might cost way
more. But did we get slightly lower
temperatures?
Yes. Yes, we did. And are we going to
segue to our sponsor? I'm chiller than
you are. And I'm going to prove it. Big
test coming up. No sweat off my back.
Dinner with the president of puppies.
Cool as a cucumber. Phone about to die
during a night on the town. I'm good. UG
Green's Magflow Pro has me feeling like
I'm wearing a leather jacket, hair
sllicked back, shades on. It's a liquid
cooled G2 25 watt power bank where you
can see the cooling in action with your
eyes thanks to the cryopulse coolant
window. It keeps peak temperatures up to
18° Fahrenheit lower than industry
standards when you charge a phone. This
compact bad boy has an attached USBC
cable and 10,000 milliamp hours of
capacity, so it can get your 17 Pro Max
halfway juiced in just 40 minutes and
completely charge it twice. And I can't
think of anything cooler than a friend.
So get your charger a buddy with UG
Green's Magflow Pro wireless charging
stand. It uses quiet fans to pull heat
away from the charging stand. It isn't
just the life of the party. It is the
party. charging iPhone, AirPods, and
Apple Watch all at once. Grab your UG
Green Mag Flow Pro at the link below.
That rhymed, so it's cool. If you guys
enjoyed this video and you love Lionus
and Elijah energy, or as I call it,
Elijah,
[laughter]
that makes one of us. Why don't you
watch a shop for printers? That was a
surprisingly entertaining little outing.
I think we better turn this thing off.
Yeah, she's running out of steam, you
might say.